Good evening. Welcome to the Hillsdale
College campus here in Washington D.C.
I’m Matthew Spalding, vice president of
the College and Dean of our Van Andel
graduate school of government based
here in D.C. This is the first public
lecture of the recently formed academy for
science and freedom at Hillsdale College
the academy exists to educate the American people
about the free exchange of scientific ideas
and the proper relationship between
freedom and science in the pursuit of truth
you can read more about it at our website this
is the first of what we hope and plan to be many
lectures seminars and conferences of the academy
uh which we'll host uh which will host to combat
the recent widespread abuses of individual and
academic freedom made in the name of science
senior scholars at the academy or Dr. Jay
Bhattacharya of Stanford university Dr. Martin
Kulldorff, formerly of Harvard Medical School
and our speaker this evening Dr. Scott Atlas in
addition to being a fellow at the academy for
science and freedom dr atlas is also a senior
fellow at the hoover institution of Stanford
university he has served as a senior advisor for
health care for several presidential candidates
and has advised congress on health care reform
and from august to December 2020 he served as a
special adviser to the president united states
and a member of the white house corona virus task
force he is the author of a new book a plague upon
our house my fight at the trump white house to
stop covet from destroying America and tonight he
is speaking on the sarge to pandemic appropriately
subtitled will truth prevail Dr. Scott Atlas.
Okay thank you uh for that introduction matt and
thank everyone here for coming and special thanks
to Dr. Arnn and Hillsdale supporters for feeling
that this is a really critical time in our period
to stand up for freedom and uh
the deep politicization of science
because without science as a process to
determine truth we we're going to be in trouble
so uh it's fantastic to work with Hillsdale in
this endeavor as well as with my colleagues uh
Jay Bhattacharya and martin Kulldorff and others
and it's a great honor to be the first speaker
in this new academy so today i will talk about
the pandemic because the pandemic is not what
the academy is about but it is it has exposed
profound problems in our society uh that probably
existed beforehand but came to the fore uh in
bright colors in frightening colors uh as we still
see today during the management of this healthcare
crisis so uh to understand and set the scene for
what problems we face as a nation and what we hope
to address expose and put forth solutions to in
this academy i'll start by going through some of
the data that uh is free from the lens of politics
from censorship of the media and free from censure
of other unenlightened universities that seem to
not understand their role in providing a
forum for the free exchange of ideas now.
If you could turn your heads to the right
we'll uh look at the slides and i'm going
to go through as i always did in my career
and as i always tried to do in the task force
i'm going to go through the data because
we absolutely must live in a country
where facts matter and we are seeing an
overt denial of facts here that at times
can be frightening so to understand what's going
on we need to know the facts and then we will lead
into i will go forward and talk about what the
results of the management were of the pandemic
where we are today and how to move forward now
this all started back in early 2020 when the world
health organization came forward and made several
claims about this so-called novel virus called the
sars2 virus and those claims uh first and foremost
were that this was extremely lethal and made the
claims that were absolutely incorrect to anyone
who had any experience looking at things like
fatality rates of diseases but they took hold
rapidly in the public and why did they take hold
because they were joined in by computer modelers
who frankly were not normally in a position of
a lot of influence in the public and these
models were based on uh false assumptions
uh then the public health leaders uh came forward
and with their newfound stardom started amplifying
this false data and then that was really amplified
by the media and the social media as we know
so that the really rapid ingraining of the
public was from the media and the social media
what was claimed cyrus ii coronavirus has
a far higher fatality rate than the flu by
several orders of magnitude everyone has a
significant risk to die no one has immunity
because the virus is new hence the end for novel
everyone is dangerous and spreads the infection
asymptomatic people are major drivers of the
spread locking down which means closing schools
and businesses confining people to their
homes stopping non-coveted medical care
and eliminating travel and personal movement
will stop or eliminate the virus masks will
protect everyone and stop the spread and immune
protection is only from a vaccine and every one
of these claims is false is factually incorrect
every single one of these claims the pandemic
policy in the beginning from the white house
task force was flatten the curve we all remember
Dr. Deborah Burks getting up on the podium and
trying to explain flatten the curve which meant
reduce the rapidity of spread of the virus with a
very logical rational reason and that was so that
hospitals would not be overwhelmed so they can
continue medical care including for non-cova care
and secondarily flattening the curve delaying
the spread would allow for the development of
production of personal protective equipment
sending beds where needed around the country
from the federal uh from part of the federal
solution uh medical personnel availability for any
hospitals that would be overwhelmed and hopefully
delay so that some production of drugs or vaccines
would be initiated the problem was that that and
that that curve by the way flattening the curve
never meant reducing the number of cases never
the same if you want to be a mathematical person
looking at a curve the area under the curve didn't
change the number of cases was never supposed to
change with flatten the curve the number of deaths
was never going to decrease would flatten the
curve flatten the curve was specifically
to stop hospitals from being overcrowded
what happened sort of magically and almost
inexplicably was these same public health
leaders changed their strategy to instead of a
very temporary two-week flatten the curve stop
covered 19 cases at all costs and so what happened
was that Dr Deborah Burks who was the head of the
medical side of the task force the so-called task
force coordinator from end of February 2020 on
and Dr Anthony Fauci who was not the head of
anything except that he was the most visible
most influential task force member uh advised
lockdown school closures business restrictions and
shutdowns limits on medical care a host of other
personal mandates restrictions and quarantine and
the result of that advice was that the governors
throughout the entire country with rare exception
followed that advice in the spring of
2020 and throughout most of the year
and over 800 000 American deaths have been
attributed to the virus millions of families
so they did not stop the deaths that strategy
did not stop the dust millions of families
and children were severely harmed from the
lock downs particularly low-income families
and poor kids from that policy from the lock downs
not the violence so to conclude if anyone has that
conclusion that the united states federal pandemic
policies failed that u.s lives were lost with the
wrong policies then one must conclude that the
berks vouchers restrictions and lock downs failed
because those were the restrictions that were
widely implemented during the entire year of 2020
and beyond that was to set the record straight
on something that's very important to understand
because what we're seeing is an Orwellian attempt
by lock down advocates to blame people who were
opposed to what was implemented for the failure
of what they advised and what was implemented
now the problem at the beginning of all this
without even talking about the results of the lock
downs where the data is severely flawed these were
things i brought up at the task force by the way
no one else on the task force knew this understood
it or acknowledged it pcr testing timelines and
trends and hospitalizations and deaths quote
from covet 19 are all problematic let's talk
about pcr testing this is still a problem today
when you do pcr testing you have to do a number of
averages of the technique and that's called cycle
threshold basically to detect a piece of virus
that you want to detect at a cycle threshold of
35 which is the value that we used to report most
pcr tests in fact you can see that in the united
kingdom the NHS used a cycle threshold of even
higher 40 to 45. the us used 35 to 40 and the
FDA recommended 40. Israel uses cycle threshold
37 this is the number of averages used to detect
the the virus and the machine doesn't stop until
you detect the virus so if you're using if it
took 40 that meant it took 40 to detect the virus
it turns out that more than 97 of the positive
tests using that technique are not detecting
live contagious virus they're detecting dead
virus or minuscule amounts people that are
not a threat so the positive pcr test does not
mean you're contagious that's a problem because
you're confined you're quarantined if you have
a positive pcr test the second surprise and i
didn't know this until later was that somebody
on the task force actually knew this beside me
his name was Anthony Fauci in July 2020 he said at
a cycle threshold of 35 or more the chances of it
being replication competent meaning contagious are
minuscule in his words he said you've got to say
it's dead nucleotides period irrelevant a positive
test is not relevant if it's detecting virus
the second big issue to talk about here is we're
starting to see a little bit of discussion this
admission of this now but this is known in the
summer of 2020. i didn't get to the white house
until beginning of august end of July 2020. people
that are hospitalized and categorized as co-fort
patients are often they're that categorization
is used because they have a positive SARS test
they're not in the hospital for covet they have
in fact no symptoms of covid whatsoever they're
in the hospital for something completely unrelated
head trauma broken leg appendicitis but once they
have a positive virus test they're called covet
hospitalization how often does that occur this
is a paper from Stanford's pediatric hospital
from may 2021 that reviewed their own charts
and it turned out that about half of
patients had zero symptoms of covid but
were categorized as covet patients
just on the basis of a virus test
this is a gross overestimate of the danger
therefore of covid in children particularly
this is a study a larger study of 163 coveted
patients and children 86 of them did not have
coffin they were categorized as co-foot they
did not have coveted 86 of hospitalized patients
the cdc actually admitted this in a review
that was published in april 2021 where they
said that the uh symptoms of reviewing the
death certificates and hospitalizations in
children 35 of them did not have any
symptoms that could in their words
plausibly be categorized as attributed
to cova this is death certificates
this is saying a third of people or more who
died from covid in this cdc study over reviewing
the charts a third of patients who were called
covet deaths could not possibly have had kovac
well this is what was known it was known when i
got the to the white house in the late summer 2020
it has not changed it's not new information
it's not learned information over the past
year and a half no matter what you hear on cnn
although i'm not sure anybody here listens to cnn
the original world health organization estimate
was very high of infection fatality rate that was
actually orders of magnitude higher than what
it really was it turns out that if you're under
70 the infection fatality is 0.05 under 70. that's
relatively close to what it is from influenza
age is the most important risk factor mean age for
death was 80. uh you know 99.2 percent of deaths
are people over 55. eighty percent earned
people uh over 65. and so we we know that
it's dangerous for certain people very old people
but particularly people uh with comorbidities
one way to look at this is the age risk
the risk of fatality is thousands fold
more in old people than in children thousands fold
this is a very unique virus in that way this is a
blessing that it does not impact significantly
healthy children it's different from the flu
in influenza in California in the last
influenza season that i could get data on
5.4 of deaths and influenza were in children zero
percent of deaths from coven are in children in
California that's not to say zero deaths but
zero percent of deaths that's a rounded number
for perspective on who dies from cova the median
age of people who die from covet is equal to or
greater than the life expectancy age in Germany
Italy the UK and the USA among other countries
that's not to minimize the tragedy of people
dying who are older but it's for perspective
which you never heard out of the mouths of
the people leading the public health uh effort
i mentioned co-morbidities because age
is by far the most important risk factor
but a 75 year old marathon runner is not at high
risk for covid it's it's really old people who are
very frail or other people who are very frail
by the way and what does that mean that means
you have underlying conditions which now
everybody uses the word comorbidity it turns
out that two-thirds of people who died in the u.s
two-thirds of them had six or more comorbidities
so if you had hypertension high blood
pressure treated and no other secondary uh
no other underlying illness that's not a
risk factor to get a higher risk for death
from covet i had to explain this on the task
force uh it was either denied or they didn't
understand what i was talking about i brought
the scientific papers with me unfortunately we
had a you know we didn't have very high level
people on the medical side of the task force
the risk to and from children is very important
because this is impacted policy even today we
have schools closed and uh and children wearing
mass and and children thinking and learning that
they are a danger to others and that they
are a danger they are in danger themselves
here's the data from California relatively
recently as of a couple months ago
although there were a lot of cases
in young people in California
in ages 0-17 0 of deaths from covet in
California this is Florida under 16 zero percent
case fatality rate this is Florida under
30 zero percent fatality rate from covid
if you're young and healthy you do
you're not in danger from coven period
we knew this from all our studies all over the
world the risk to children is extremely low
if they're healthy children if you have a serious
underlying illness as a child like leukemia
or extreme obesity and other underlying conditions
that go with that okay you're at high risk there's
no question but healthy children are not period
spread from children this was proven all over
the country this is not new knowledge this was
known in late spring 2020 from studies all over
the world Norway Sweden Spain the Netherlands
Ireland England Germany Greece South Korea Israel
and Iceland children are unusual to transmit in
fact pretty rare to transmit this virus to adults
in fact schools that are open are not a high risk
setting they're a low risk setting in fact if i
could design a job where i wanted to have low
risk from covid i'd want to be a school teacher
there is no special material vaccine policy
testing policy barriers distancing or anything
else that's needed in schools if you believe in
fact in fact you know uh Sweden opened up all
their schools during 2020 during the height of
the pandemic i'm not talking about oma crime i'm
the wild type virus the regular virus the first
virus that was uh what was part of stars ii
1.8 million children attended school full-time
no masks no distancing no measures whatsoever in
sweden schools and no significant problem from
kovat were there some cases of hospitalizations
yes how many deaths were there zero healthy
children have extremely low risk of serious
illness from covet and almost no risk of death
children rarely spread the virus to adults and
there is absolutely no special risk to teachers in
school any teacher who says that there's certain
conditions that have to be met is making excuses
and does not have the interest of your children
in her the case to open schools i made the
case at an event in the white house when i
first got there in early august and that
case is very simple healthy children have
do not have a significant risk from this virus the
harms of closing in person schools are enormous
to children and there is absolutely nothing more
important to a civilized society than educating
its children the second part of this stuff is the
harms of the closures that is never spoken about
online learning is a failure and it is not
just because people don't have computers in
the country in the world with the most widespread
broadband access and computers the Netherlands
they had severe drops in learning in
children particularly in certain uh
classes of families meaning less educated parents
for instance again highlighting that the lock
downs were a luxury of the rich the affluence
had no significant problem with the lock downs
but the people that those same elite class pretend
to care about working class lower income families
they were destroyed by the lockdowns and
their children were specifically harmed
from the school closures in virginia nearby
here of course this was early data from
i think summer of 2020 that had already been
compiled massive explosion of failing grades up 83
reading and math losses 30 to 50 just after the
spring 2020 closure these closures went on for for
months and even the full year in most of the
country a stanford study said the findings on
learning losses are chilling that was the first
sentence of their conclusion again all of these
losses were far greater for minorities in the
poor and there were other losses that people
presumably in this room don't really think about
a lot of kids that's the first place they get
hearing or vision problems detected because they
don't have a family doctor necessarily they have
nutritional needs met all of our children
go to school to learn conflict resolution
group interactions physical activity you can learn
a lot online but you can't learn socialization
what about more serious heart this is compared
year to year the 2020 lockdown year versus the
previous year closing in-person schools and
mental health and teenagers is the title of
the slide but what this slide shows is there
was a significant drop in all medical claims
to doctors all medical visits by teenagers
because medical care was disrupted significantly
but there was an explosion of mental health
claims this is actual insurance claim data
comparing year to year 2020 to the previous
year of 2019. that's mental health claims
what about this slide this is a tripling of
self-harm visits year to year by teenagers
during the lockdown because of the isolation these
are what do we mean self-harm we mean children
putting cigarettes out on their skin slashing
their wrists and i'm being graphic intentionally
here because these are real people that
were impacted this is not about stopping
of respiratory virus that by the way children
have no significant risk from if they're healthy
this is generalized anxiety disorder major
depressive disorder and adjustment disorder
an explosion in college-aged children harms
to the younger generation due to the lockdown
the isolation this is explosion of overdoses
substance use by teenagers this is all teenager
year to year data 2020 lockdown year versus 2019.
and there are many many other things i could quote
i won't go through the whole slide but just
to cite that in a july cdc study from 2020
they said that three-fourths of college-aged
children in the united states reported at least
one mental health system symptom by june 2020
and there was one in four of our college-age
children thought of killing himself in june
of 2020 because of that first spring lockdown
mandela said there can be no keener revelation of
a society's soul than the way in which it treats
his children the way the united states has treated
his children is a disgrace and i'm saying that
specifically because this country is an outlier
we are the only country among our peer nations
that close schools in the fall of 2020. all the
european countries almost without exception knew
the data and they opened their schools we didn't
something like 17 of kids in the us had in-person
instruction now lockdown is very important
because it's a dirty word now and the people
who are the lockdown advocates know it's a dirty
word so they try to run away from their own policy
lockdown means closing schools and businesses
limiting medical care for non-covet illnesses
limiting personal interactions including seeing
your own grandparents or grandchildren restricting
personal movement travel curfews and quarantining
low-risk asymptomatic people that's locked down
what did the lockdowns do they failed why do i
say that well this is bjorn study march 2021 on
the left looking at the data in mortality from
24 european countries the more severe lockdown
policies did not reduce death from kovac this is
bhattacharya ben david o and ian's january 2021
first authors ben david they looked at the spread
restrictive lockdowns did not reduce the growth of
cases in fact johnny andes was quoted as saying
the lockdowns in many cases were pro contagion
because remember the lockdowns can find people
indoors this is completely antithetical to simple
common sense for a virus that's spread indoors and
the most striking study of all that i recommend
everyone look at who wants to be informed from
data is the study from rand institute in june
2021 that said that the analyzed lockdown policies
in 43 countries and in all the u.s states and what
they found was that with longer shelter-in-place
orders there was an increase in excess death
access deaths are that's beyond baseline of a
non-pandemic here so longer in shelter-in-place
orders longer lockdowns more access does faster
lockdowns earlier onset more excess deaths in the
43 countries with available data the excess deaths
were falling before the lockdowns but once the
lockdowns were instituted the excess deaths began
increasing at the time of the lockdowns and that
was also true in the united states where deaths
increased once the lockdowns were implemented
the false dichotomy was set up to make
people believe that lock guns were the
only way to go now what do i mean by that
well this is back in the spring of 2020
where i wrote a paper because i wondered
where were the economists the economist
knew from decades of literature that a
severe economic shutdown will kill people
yet the false dichotomy was set up by the lockdown
advocates that people that were against the
lockdowns were choosing money economy over life
but it really was a lie it was a false statement
it was lives versus life we did a study i did this
because i was called up by one of the university
of chicago economist uh john burge we did
this uh together with ralph keaney from duke
and alexander lipton uh who was from uh
university of jerusalem and we quantified
that the loss of life years by may of 2020 was
double from the lockdown than from the virus
why would that happen because
medical care was shut down
first of all okay we might not remember it but
half of a 650 000 u.s cancer patient population
skipped their chemotherapy they were afraid
to come into a hospital 40 of stroke patients
half of heart attack patients did not call an
ambulance they were afraid to come into a hospital
organ transplants from living donors were down
85 from the previous year these medical illnesses
did not go away everybody understands that of
course but you don't you don't think about it
more than two-thirds of cancer screenings
were skipped what do you think is going to
happen to these people the cancers didn't go away
they're going to come back with widespread disease
what's called metastatic disease which is severe
pain severe suffering and many of them will die
because they skip their cancer screenings
and their chemotherapy if they had a cancer
severe child abuse cases brought to the emergency
room skyrocketed it wasn't bad enough that two to
three hundred thousand child abuse cases were
not reported in the spring of 2020 alone in the
u.s because the schools were closed the schools
are the number one agency to notice child abuse
but massive increases in the cases
that were brought to the emergency room
now what does that mean okay i've been a doctor
where i've had to come in the middle of the night
and look at a head ct scan and tell the
police is standing there this baby cannot
go home with these people this is child abuse
and so when you're used to that and you know
what happens with people the people that
bring their child into the emergency room
who beat the child they think they killed the
child these are the most severe cases skyrocketed
by 35 i was getting emails from emergency room
doctors all over the country including in michigan
by the way speaking of hillsdale telling me
what was going on in their emergency rooms
during the first two months of the pandemic two
months more than one-third of u.s excess deaths
were not due to covet those were lockdown
desks the lockdowns literally killed people
the lockdowns as i say are the luxury of the rich
why is that because not only were people able to
order in their food have people from
amazon come in and deliver their stuff
get together with their neighbors
in the neighborhoods like where i
live in palo alto where everybody's got a
phd and you can have a little home school
regular people don't have that but even worse this
is national data unemployment low wage jobs during
the first year or so of the lockdown dropped by
23.6 high rates high wage jobs increased by 2.4
the lockdowns of the united states inflicted
worldwide harms we don't think about this stuff
but when you look at the numbers it's staggering
and what i mean by the lockdowns are the lockdowns
and the advice of the faces of public health
leadership of the us because these people are
listened to all over the world everybody in
the world knows who dr fauci is the public
health leaders of these other countries they're
influenced by the public health leaders of the
united states we are an interconnected world
obviously economically there's there's no way
to disentangle what happens in a poor country
when the u.s shuts down that's where they
get their income and so we look at things like
interruption of medical care and the supply chain
to these poorer countries this year alone there
will be 400 000 new deaths from tuberculosis
alone tens of thousands of additional malaria
doesn't babies occurred in 2020 because they
couldn't get the resources they couldn't get
the malaria nuts everything was locked down
the medications were disrupted one and a half
billion children were shut out of education
a hundred million more children
this is unicef projection
or were and uh other international organizations
a hundred million more children will suffer sexual
abuse and exploitation violence genital mutilation
and childhood pregnancies because of the lockdown
when poverty occurs because of
economic shutdown in a poor country
life expectancy falls not everywhere in the world
is the united states when you have countries in
africa southeast asia thrown into abject poverty
97 million more people in 2020 alone were thrown
into extreme poverty what does that mean that
means they get less than 1.90 a day to live liver
okay so uh in places like
bangladesh is one example
their whole gdp really depends on almost
almost depends on one industry garment
manufacturing for the western nations
you shut down the u.s and western europe
you've wiped up the total income for
4.1 million families in bangladesh
this is the analysis of the impact
of the lockdown on a global basis
that was published in the uh summer of 2021
analyzing 124 countries and it showed number
one the countries with the biggest reductions
in mobility meaning the lockdowns were associated
with the biggest losses of life and 1.2 billion
life years were lost due to the lockdowns 25
times as many life years as was lost due to covet
the lockdowns failed to protect the elderly
they failed to stop the spread of the virus
they killed people and destroyed families and
sacrificed children especially low-income and
the poor while sparing the affluent that's the
science for people who want to quote the sign
now the alternative always existed i said it
after johnny and edie said it from stanford
in late february early march and then several
other people said it sinatra gupta of oxford
jay bhattacharya and martin kaldorf my
colleagues in this hillsdale initiative
and several other people the alternative was
focused or targeted protection this was not even
complicated this is simple common sense we knew
who was at high risk we knew who wasn't at high
risk let's protect the people at high risk
and not destroy the people at low risk yet
that wasn't done and what that means is increasing
the protection of the high risk group monitoring
hospitals and sending supplies and opening
schools medical care businesses and transportation
for the low-risk people and the people who want
to go and live their lives now this was called
dangerous this was the second lie perpetrated
by the lockdown advocates the first was you're
choosing money over life the second was anyone
who's against the lockdowns is dangerous because
you're advocating something that they deemed
what's called herd immunity strategy which of
course i was accused of many times in the press i
never said that of course because what that means
to these people was letting the
virus spread survival of the fittest
let it go and whoever survived survives will
build up population community that's not what i
recommended that's not what anybody recommended
that i knew that was never said in the white
house never said to the president united states
i never even heard anyone talk like that what we
said was increase the protection with specific
measures of the people who were dying from the
current lockdown policy the berks fauci policy
was not protecting the older high-risk people
finally in october uh the something called
the great barrington declaration was written
co-authored by again two of my colleagues here uh
dr koldorf and dr bhattacharya and sinatra gupta
uh these people are all at the top level
of epidemiology medical science vaccine
scientists at some of the what we used to
think of as elite universities i'm not so
sure i buy into that anymore but um this was
claimed as fringe in fact we've seen the emails
recently by between the head of the
nih francis collins and dr fauci uh
um instigating media attack on this on these
authors calling them fringe and using their
power to get what they called a quote take down
of these scientists okay this is you know as far
as i know unprecedented it's a shameful way to end
their careers and i'm happy this is being recorded
because i want that statement on record it was
also said when uh i was saying that i believe
in the core principles of the great barrington
declaration that was increasing protection for the
people at high risk and stopping the damage of the
lockdowns that's the gist of the great barrington
declaration president biden as candidate went on
60 minutes and said no one agrees with dr atlas no
credible doctor and i say well when i look
at a statement here that's signed by 15 000
medical scientists and 44 000 medical
practitioners and about a million people that's a
lot of nobodies that's my answer to that criticism
now it turns out that it wasn't just that the
lockdowns failed to stop the infection to stop the
death and inflicted we damage an internal control
like we say in in a medical experiment and that is
we have a state that didn't do the lockdowns that
instead tried to do targeted protection that state
is florida after the initial shutdowns governor uh
desantis decided to open all schools at
the end of august 2020 to not have mandated
uh business closures and what do we see from
the results okay well after one full year
of that florida outperformed the average
u.s and deaths per capita from coveted
florida outperformed 25 states remember the other
states did the lockdowns the burden is not on
florida to outperform the other states the burden
is on the states that imposed collateral damage
to save lives compared to florida florida doesn't
have to do better because they didn't destroy
people's lives they didn't kill people with
the lockdowns the excess mortality incredible
increase after a year florida outperformed by 24
percent the average in the us and outperformed
two-thirds of the states age-adjusted covert
mortality which is important because as you
know this is a disease that really impacts old
people and spares young people generally and
florida has a lot of old people and so we look at
the age-adjusted covet mortality after one year
florida outperformed by 40 percent the average
in the us they outperformed 40 states and they
outperformed 40 states for people 65 and over
outperformed because of targeted protection
now let's compare florida and california where i
live because they're sort of similar california
and florida are very large diverse states mixed
urban rural relatively similar weather although
i strongly prefer california weather to florida
uh but um the key differences were florida's the
fifth oldest state in the country this is
a disease that kills old people selectively
basically california is the seventh youngest state
in the country so right away we're saying okay
california has an advantage here
to begin with for this disease
secondly the comparison which i'm getting
at is that florida was open widely since
late summer 2020 california's had one of
the longest most stringent lockdown policies
what do we see well in the top graph on the
right that's florida green as schools were
open since fall 2020. and the bottom we see
green as what schools are open in california
again less than 20 percent of students for
a year had in-person schools in california
what about protecting people from dying
this is after one year age-adjusted covert
mortality rate worse in california than florida
access mortality increased worse in
california than florida that's after one year
now what happened is the media and normal people i
guess and i don't consider the media normal people
um like to take a point in time and say aha okay
now look at florida okay so they did that at the
late summer 2021 when there was a surge
of cases in the south on that graph you
can see that yellow and bright toward the
white is increased cases whereas the rest
of the country's pretty dark meaning not a lot of
cases that was the surge in the late summer 2021
and they said wow look what happened well i wrote
in the preface of my book the forward of my book
that and i was writing it at the time i said
what's going to happen of course is that the cases
are going to go down in florida and then go up
in the rest of the country because how did i know
that which is exactly what happened on the october
third map very few cases in the south in florida
the rest of the country was basically exploding
how did i know that because that's what happened
last year identical last year meaning the year
before this is july 2020 cases in the south texas
florida not much elsewhere and then in the fall
exploding in the rest of the country and very few
so you have to be careful when you're making
the comparison so i gave you the comparison
after one year now i'm giving you the comparison
after the entire pandemic relatively to date here
this is january 7th access mortality during the
whole pandemic california did worse than florida
no matter what you hear from the politicians
in california they either don't know the data
or they're lying those are the only two options
this is age-adjusted coveted mortality by state
this is at the end of the year 2021 and we see
that florida outperformed more than half the
states roughly uh 60 of the states and it's about
the same as californian age-adjusted mortality
this preacher evolves of course because this
doesn't include some deaths but we'll see what
happens but basically again the burden is on
the other states not on florida to prove they
did better let's talk about the vaccines this
is a topic that everybody wants to hear about
this is the data on the vaccines i'm not going to
give you any of the opinion i'm going to show you
the graphs from the studies and then we'll talk
about what they show this is data from israel that
showed that the vaccines back analyzed in mid
after summer 2021 the vaccines were very good
for stopping people from getting severe disease or
dying roughly 90 effective that's that's very good
and not very good at stopping you from
getting another infection 39 effective after
only roughly six months five five months
this is their data uh on symptomatic infection
regular any infection symptomatic infection
hospitalization and severe covet or death
hospitalization or severe covid again 90
for the duration of the study the problem with
not understanding that and claiming uh on one hand
that the vaccines don't work is you're undermining
the confidence people should have in the value
of the vaccines the vaccines prevent people from
dying and i'm going to show you more data on this
this is a study from qatar october 2021. why
would i look at qatar by the way you'd think
oh why would i trust qatar well first of all i
don't trust the data coming out of the cdc and
so i'm forced to look at other countries second
of all qatar actually they vaccinated almost our
entire population they were very rigid about
it so it provides a good sort of experimental
setting and they looked at protection against
death hospitalization and infection and here's
what they show and what i'm going to show you here
is that after four months there's only about a 20
effectiveness of getting another against getting
another virus infection so after four months the
protection against getting an infection from
the with vaccine uh is is minimal it disappears
this is the protection again of vaccinated people
against getting severe critical fatal cases of
covet very high down here you can't comment
because this error bar means there's very
few cases so through the duration of the
study you're talking 85 90 effectiveness
against death and severe disease that's very
good this is a study from sweden this is the
effectiveness of the vaccination against the
risks as i talked about of up to nine months
the vaccine effectiveness against getting coveted
meaning a set of symptoms due to the sars virus
dropped significantly in all comers
after about four months like qatar's data
what about against hospitalization or
death after about nine months it still
it drops when you take all comers but i looked
at their data and made a new graph from their
data this is their data it's not in the paper and
it shows that people that are under 80 years old
the protection against death is very high
this is sweden the protection drops against
death in people who are over 80 after about
six months to about 50 so there is a waning
of protection from of the vaccine against
dying but not for people under 80. this is
the data we know so far remember this is a new
vaccine we don't we haven't had this for years
here's the study the follow-up study on comparing
those who've had the infection versus those who've
been vaccinated but never had the infection
this is the israel study from late summer
people who have recovered from covet but never
been vaccinated have a 27 fold fewer cases
than people who've been vaccinated but never had
covert okay this is the point that you get coveted
you get natural what people call natural immunity
this is not news by the way it would have been a
shock if this wasn't true this is biology that you
learn in high school if you're taking ap biology
every single competent doctor should know this
this is expected this is proven in other viruses
and it is also proven in this virus people
who have recovered from covet but never been
vaccinated have a 13 fold decrease incidence
of any infection compared to people who've
been vaccinated and never had coven and people
who've had covenant recovered but never vaccinated
have an eightfold decrease in incidence of covart
that requires hospitalization compared to people
who've been vaccinated but never infected
the protection of having had coveted without
vaccination is better than the protection of
having had vaccination without covert that's fact
it turns out that they also looked at the
people who've been vaccinated who've been
recovered from the infection but never vaccinated
versus recovered and then vaccinated just in case
and they looked at what happened with these two
groups against symptomatic infection no difference
against all infection no difference there's no
difference in the israel data between people
who've been recovered from covet and never
vaccinated and recovered from covet and then
vaccinated no difference no benefit to the
vaccine and people recovered from covert
that's what that israel studies show the
follow-up study from israel december 2021
they had three categories of people recovered
but never vaccinated recovered then vaccinated
or vaccinated then recovered
and then what happened later
all three categories had equivalent protection
against another sars infection that means people
who've been recovered from the infection with
or without a vaccine have the same protection
that's the israel data all three groups anyone
who's recovered with or without a vaccine
has far fewer new infections than people who've
been double vaccinated but never infected that's
a fact protection against severe covet because
that's really what counts if you think about it
recovered people recovered then vaccinated
vaccinated and recovered have the exact
equivalent protection against severe covenant
that means people who've had the virus and
recovered compared to people who've been
vaccinated and also had the virus no benefit
in that study to being vaccinated
for people who've had the virus
people who've been vaccinated have afford
a tenfold higher rate of severe covet
than people who've recovered from cove at
once even if they've never been vaccinated
this is a graph of that this is the easier slide i
should have shown first this is time left to right
the blue is p light blue are people that have
been vaccinated but never had coveted what is the
incidence of getting infected it's increasing
over time these curves are people who've been
vaccinated then recovered
alone never vaccinated and
that and recovered and then vaccinated
they're all the same over time and much
lower than the people who've been vaccinated
but never infected in terms of new infections
that's not opinion
this is newer data on omicron this is denmark
december 20th study time since vaccine pfizers
and modernism protection against omicron okay
after two months the protection against omicron in
fully vaccinated people is between four and nine
percent okay that's that's nearly zero right in
two months if you're getting vaccines repeatedly
to stop you from getting the infections like
omicron and it takes two weeks to generate
antibodies to the vaccine you're gonna have to
get an injection every month every single month
forever this is something i didn't highlight but
at the bottom of the slide this is their data on
the booster protection against omicron at the peak
of its protection meaning at the end of one month
54 only stoppage of new infections at the peak
of the boosters protection against homicide
that's just the same size so here's the summary
covet vaccines protect against death and
severe disease and that's very important
to understand for the people who keep insisting
the vaccines don't work i don't agree with that
statement that's not what the data shows the
vaccines protect against severe disease and
death and if you're high risk for that there's
a case to be made you should take the vaccine
vaccines protect against infection
but that protection is very temporary
it drops to very low after only four months and
nearly zero against omicron after only two months
so it's personally protective in terms of
stopping you from dying but it does not stop
you from getting an infection in a few months
and therefore in spreading an infection so
another way to look at it is it's a private
protective measure but it is not protecting
people who you think are a danger to it's
not stopping the spread there's no public
benefit to having vaccines of other people you're
worried you're high risk get the vaccine you're
not stopping the spread of the infection from
other people by forcing them to get the vaccine
vaccines do not protect against infection or
symptomatic infection as well as the immunity
of recovered patients that's factually true
and that was acknowledged this week maybe
two days ago by the cdc finally there are safety
concerns about the vaccines the biggest problem of
all is simply we don't have the data there's
been a a really harmful lack of transparency
about the safety data on the vaccines remember
most vaccines don't give us all the safety data
until five years we have a vaccine here that
was done very quickly in a health emergency but
you can't even assess the safety of a
vaccine this quickly but we have not had
even full transparency about the side effects and
we know that young males particularly but not only
have a certain risk of myocarditis from the
vaccine remember they don't have a significant
risk if they're healthy from the disease so in
my book you're having a situation where you're
injecting healthy children with a vaccine for
a disease they don't have significant risk for
what about covet vaccines and children
this is a quote a shameful quote from
the editor-in-chief of the new england journal
eric rubin october 26th quote but we're never
going to learn about how safe this vaccine
is unless we start giving it that's just the
way it goes i never thought that would
be said in the united states of america
this is a quote from another country because
i said we were an outlier with closing schools
we're an outlier with the vaccines for children
we keep pushing vaccines for children in our
schools and elsewhere healthy children the uk's
advisory committee said the margin of benefit
based primarily on a health perspective
is too small to support advice on a
universal program of vaccination of
otherwise healthy 12 to 15 year olds
where is the moral and ethical concerns
of our u.s public health leaders
america's media has contributed to the frenzy in
the united states and it's been uniquely harmful
this is a study comparing this is i think
november 2020 comparing the english-speaking media
in the us versus elsewhere negative coveted
stories u.s major media 91 quantifiably negative
non-us english language media only 54 negative
we had the same pandemics as western europe had
the u.s media stories of increasing cases
outnumbered the stories of decreasing cases in
2020 by a factor of five even when the cases were
declining there was a distortion of what was going
on by the united states media including about
schools what is the legacy of that the legacy is
a damaged public particularly younger generation
i talked about the the the psychological impacts
that were horrendous what about just simply softer
things like fear okay this is in in the summer of
2020. this is in purple the share of respondents
worried that it was serious health effects coming
to their generation compared to the reality the
younger generations were grossly exaggerating
by factors of 100 or more how dangerous the virus
was to them whereas people that were over 65 they
had a rational assessment of what was going
on and they were the only ones really at risk
in fact there's a survey done on uh
spring of 2021 and we notice here
that people in college asian united states
half of them said they were nervous about
any social interaction again i mean that
that's striking to me that is really tragic
you know public health is more than just stopping
this virus during the lockdown americans gained a
lot of weight but what i'm pointing out here is
that college age generation 52 of them had an
unwanted weight gain during the 2020 lockdown
and that weight gain averaged 28 pounds
that's a that's obesity that's a public health
problem that's not a cosmetic extra five pounds
i mean it's really incredible now all of this
is getting to the point of the talk which is
why we're so uh focused on this in this hillsdale
initiative of the academy for science and freedom
because we have lost trust rightfully
so in institutions that we need to trust
one of course is media and social media another is
science public health agencies scientific journals
teachers and education leaders and academia in
general why have we lost us because they've given
erratic advice often directly contrary to the
evidence they've falsely declared consensus in
scientific journals on things that were simply
false let alone no consensus and by the way
you don't declare what science has shown by saying
we are in consensus here that's not how it works
there's been a gross politicization of science the
scientific journals including the best journals
in the world lancet new england journal
british medical journal jama have been
publishing diatribes against people who just
simply disagreed with the interpretation of
the data that they wanted to hear instead of
criticizing the data they've been character
smears that's politicization of science
there's been intimidation and censure
on university campuses which is reprehensible
destructive to the free exchange of ideas that
universities are supposed to stand
for and dangerous because these are
the people in charge of educating our
children the nation's future leaders
there's been overt censorship in the media they've
pulled down youtube videos not just of me of many
people uh governor desantis had a panel on
the pandemic management early in uh 20 uh 2021
he asked me dr bhattacharya called orphan gupta
to participate in this panel open to the press
we had q a youtube pulled it down and said it was
misinformation it's the governor of florida uh and
for you know pretty credentialed uh researchers
on the pandemic and luckily we had a governor in
florida who called me up the next day and said
we're going to do another panel on the pull
down by youtube so you can't be afraid you have to
continue thank god for people that understand that
now i want to talk specifically about what's
happening on university campuses because
hillsdale is a university campus and hillsdale
doesn't do this and this is a direct contrast
to why we need university leaders who understand
that this kind of behavior that i'm going to point
out is unacceptable to a university there's
this this is sort of a story of three stanford
university medical scientists johnny andes
myself and jay bhattacharya and we all said
the identical things about who's at risk about the
risk to children about immunity from the infection
about the ineffectiveness of masks about how
schools should open about the harms of lockdowns
and about the way to do this was focus protection
and not only do i know we said the same things i
often said exactly what they said i was talking
to them almost every day for almost the whole year
yet only one of us was issued an official rebuke
from faculty members in the stanford university
uh faculty senate i wonder why okay and the why
is because i had the audacity to think that i
should help the country under a president that the
stanford university faculty doesn't like and why
do i say that that's so political it's not just
i'm i'm thinking this this is the voting record
of stanford zip code where i happen to live and
compared to california that by the trump vote
in the state of california was two to one
in stanford zip code which you have to be a
faculty member basically or high-level staff to
live ninety-five percent by three percent trump
the problem right now is that the
free exchange of ideas that are
obviously fundamental not just to this country to
all free societies is under threat and without the
united states having freedom of speech i don't
think that any other country is going to end up
with freedom like this so what are we doing about
it well this is what we're doing about it here
uh dr earn and the supporters of hillsdale and
the people that comprise hillsdale are committed
to fixing the problem with at least science and
because without freedom in science you don't have
science there is no such thing as science without
the free exchange the interpretations uh the the
debate that's how you win the argument if you're
not capable of doing that you don't even belong at
the table but science is not done by decree and so
uh myself uh dr koldorf and dr bhattacharya were
here in this room uh on december 10th announcing
this new academy which we will operate uh mainly
out of the dc campus but we will be uh the purpose
really is to first educate the american people
about what is happening here because it's shocking
to me how often i give a talk like this and so
many people come up and say they've never heard
any of this okay because of this was not allowed
to be presented and it's pretend to think we're
learning this stuff now the harms and lockdowns
were done while we knew everything i showed
you here except for the stuff about the vaccine
effectiveness and we have a continuation of today
so we're going to educate the american people
uh hopefully with the help of press who
are interested in making this visible
and uh we're going to try to explore solutions
and so this is the first event of many we're
going to have lectures like this seminars
group discussions panels some of which involve
the media some of which involve students mainly
in dc but also in other campuses of of hillsdale
and we hope that people here that support
freedom uh are going to support this initiative
i'll finish with a couple of quick slides here
this is i gave a talk at the university of
milan law school about a month ago on coven
where okay this is a country that has been
hurt very much italy uh by covid uh but as
opposed to what i see in the universities in the
united states they asked me to give a talk at the
university and they we went out to dinner and they
were they were in they were very interested in the
data that i was presenting it was very civilized
and i think the us has lost a lot of that
humanity frankly but this is a slide that
i showed in milan because it's the main
newspaper of italy corriere la delicera
in 1992 which after 359 years the catholic church
admitted that the earth moved that galileo was
right and i'm betting that the lockdowners
are going to take longer than 359 years
so to finish a quote that i think
dr aaron appreciates because he's
a winston churchill scholar truth is
incontrovertible panic may resent it
ignorance may deride it malice may distort
it but there it is thank you very much
thank you so we have some time um for questions
and i i think this is important to ask questions
because uh everybody has questions about what
they've heard what they've seen and we have
roving microphones and so we're gonna start out
with the back of the room uh hi there my name is
philip wegman no one pays me for my opinion but
i'm a journalist and i would like to know that um
during our interview because that was remarkable
at the time my question though is i remember in
march of 2020 trump said in the briefing room that
the cure could not be worse than the disease and
the after action report that you've presented
here has been very helpful but as you noted
a lot of what you've presented except
for the vaccines was known at the time
so as you look back what was the i guess
blockage in the supply chain that stopped
uh warning about lockdowns from getting to the
president who is the decision making yeah i mean
it's you know when i go through i wrote a book
the play a plague upon our house to document
the history of what actually happened there
is nobody else that will give you the honest
view of what happened inside that task force
room during the four months that i was there
and advising the president and to set the
historical record and to try to answer some
of these very questions what i saw so i didn't get
there till the end of july beginning of august and
uh dr burks was in charge of the task force from
the end of february 2020 onward so for six months
the task force was focused on locking down closing
up everything restricting medical care etc but
the president was on record several times as you
just mentioned saying wait a second common sense
uh we're going to destroy children by having
schools closed we're going to destroy society by
shutting all businesses and this virus only
really is is severely dangerous to certain people
why don't we protect them he said this
in his common-sense way several times
um the difference was when i got there i i knew
all the data about it and uh had been saying this
independently of course for for us for five six
months but dr burks and dr fauci were delegated
the authority okay they they from my
understanding they went to the president
they convinced him that 15 days short
period of time we're going to do a shutdown
and i think that's a persuasive argument i think
for any of us if we would have thought 15 days
to shut down that in the end will be
a blip people can handle 15 days even
though it will be somewhat harmful but then
it evolved into this frenzy this obsession
with stopping all cases of covid which was
irrational uh and just simply against all biology
of what we knew about respiratory viruses and my
my um my experience there was uh if you're asking
me why did that why was that message allowed okay
the way it was set up was the white house task
force which was run by dr burke's on the medical
side and the logistics side was separate the
logistical side was sort of operational and that
was running pretty well although they stumbled
very badly early on with testing before i got
there uh but uh the medical side was mainly dr
berks who was the task force coordinator
dr fauci who was the public face of it all
uh and dr redfield the head of the cdc and what i
saw were people who uh when i was asked a question
about an issue like what's the risk to children
in schools i came prepared with a dozen or 20
scientific articles from the world's publication
the data i went through a critique of the studies
that weren't very good if the design was poor
the conclusion was invalid etc i was met i
never saw once any of the three of them bring
in a scientific paper i never saw once any of
them refute what i said with scientific data i
never saw them disagree with each other once in
any of the meetings that i came to and what that
means that's a red flag scientists are known to
disagree with each other um and all i was met with
was the accusation that i was an outlier or fringe
and so this is not the behavior of scientists
this is the behavior of government bureaucrats
the policy was delegated to people who were in
government bureaucrat positions for 35 and 40
years the way people survive in government
bureaucrat positions now this is my opinion
is not because they're politically neutral but
because they're politically savvy they know how
to navigate a highly politicized environment
they have friends in your profession in the
media uh they have friends uh in the agencies
and it turned out these three was revealed by dr
uh burks after i left they had a pact fauci
burton redfield they were all going to quit
if one of them got fired by president trump
does that impress you as people interested
in helping stopping people from dying and helping
the country okay i'll let you make the conclusion
the other thing that was very striking to me
was not only the non-scientific complete lack
of critical thinking there was this bizarre very
uh sophomoric really tabulation of cases that they
were showing that you could download from any
public website that's not analysis okay they
were saying correlation of two things happening
meant causation you know if i uh if i get up early
that day and it's sunny did i cause the sun to
come out or did it just happen at the same time
this is the level of the thinking there and i'm
not exaggerating it happened with the masked
issue uh but then the other difference that i
saw was these people were not were interested
uh in not we're not interested in having the
scientific debate at all i brought in experts in
virus uh science in vaccines in pediatric
infectious disease from coast to coast to
meet with the president why because i was an
advisor i wanted him to get the information
i want him to have his questions answered by the
people doing the research on the pandemic from
ucla tufts medical center harvard and stanford
we set that meeting up so dr burke specifically
could attempt i wrote about this in the book so
it's public but she refused to come she canceled
right before the meeting the day before not
because she had a conflict she didn't want to come
this is not the behavior of somebody who is a
scientist you want to speak to the people doing
the research you want to bounce your ideas off
of them you want to hear what they have to say
if you're not confident enough that you
can discuss differences with other expert
scientists you don't belong in the room first of
all but second of all uh it's just frightening
who was in charge of the policy and the if
there is a a problem with the way it was
done uh i believe that there were some political
uh concerns with people advising the president
who said and they told me i'm saying this because
they told me the quote that i kept hearing was
don't rock the boat scott don't rock the boat and
i kept saying the boat is frigging capsized okay
people are dying the place was out of control
the country's off the rails the boats capsized
okay i'm not worried about rocking the boat
but there was a political issue a concern
and it was very difficult when you had people are
heavily credentialed we have people like dr fauci
uh and dr burks give an adulation in the media
propped up on a pedestal have scientific
credentials and we're talking to people
who have no medical knowledge whatsoever in the
white house it's difficult to go against that
even though the president did speak against that
because he knew the policy was wrong and it was
failing and it was dangerous and so uh it's a very
difficult environment washington dc it's political
uh inherently uh and it was uh very difficult
to navigate for somebody who was basically
like me and neophyte i didn't know what was
going on in the beginning frankly uh but um
we see from the exposure of the emails and the
email troves that these people were politicized
people they were political they were trying to
smear other people instead of spending their time
doing the drug trials that should
have been done doing the debates
uh and interested in other opinions so the bottom
line was long-winded answer the policies were
taken over by bureaucrats that should
have never been in charge of this policy
yes can you wait for the microphone
thank you day after day day after
day hour after hour we saw dr
fauci and we saw dr burks behind him and
it occurred to me from a pr point of view
that an economist should have equal time maybe a
stephen moore munchen whomever from a think tank
from a uh university research university did the
task force ever even once approach president trump
and say to the american people that are
experiencing this bad economy the economy
that's sinking we think from a pr point of view
it would be good to balance faucet with some kind
of economist did that ever get played there were
economists involved in the task force in the room
in the task force meetings um and they pointed
out everything but the message to the public
was simply stopping covet 19 cases that was
the visible messenger dr fauci and dr burke
so remember dr burks by the way as task force
coordinator gave all of the writing and written
medical advice to the states all of it she
wrote it to the governors every one of them
she visited dozens of states with or without
the vice president i visited one state by the
way during my time there florida i didn't
visit any other state so the task force
official federal guideline was dr burke's the
visible face on tv and in the media was dr fauci
they never voiced never not once in my presence
anything about the harms of the lockdowns never
yes
hi uh thanks first of all for for a very
informative talk and thanks for all that you've
done thus far my question has to do with actual
treatment uh non-hospitalization type treatment
um that tell me if i'm wrong but i think
i'm right and that there's virtually no
prescribed protocol for treating kovid other
than if you get really sick go to the hospital
um there appear to be some drugs out there that
are at least to some degree effective in at least
in a prophylactic sense early in the stages of
the disease but there's no official policy by any
medical school or certainly government agencies i
think that's correct and and if it is then why why
do you think it is that yeah well the way first of
all the way medicine is practiced is generally um
not so rigidly number one in general it's not
necessarily true that there's an official way
to treat something but there are standard ways to
treat diseases you're pointing out something a big
big issue which is first of all there are drugs
that uh that are effective some of which were
developed under operation warp speed which are the
monocle antibodies for instance if you're a person
who's symptomatic and you're an outpatient and
you're high risk you should go to get monoclonal
antibodies they decrease the hospitalization rate
by 70 percent in people who are high risk that's
what the data was um and so that's that's very
important there are other drugs that are coming
out uh the the biggest issue that you're getting
at probably or i will make that leap is that
there was a gross failure of nih to do the
clinical trials on widely available cheap
safe drugs that were already fda approved like
hydroxy chloroquine if your mechanism these are
drugs that have a mechanism of action it's
called that suggests that they should work
and so we're two years into a pandemic and
we've still never done these definitive trials
sponsored by the nih the nih is supposed to do
the drug trials the question is why did they
do that i don't know the answer but i do know
that they inculcated inappropriate fear in
people about hydroxychloroquine immediately after
the president said prematurely hydroxychloroquine
works for covid and once that phrase was said
there was a massive pushback again you have to
say it's political uh during the election year
uh somehow refuting that even though it wasn't
known and so like i say there were indications
that it should work in the laboratory there
was some anecdotal data but the nih did not do
the definitive trials and in fact they claimed
that the they and many people others claim this
drug was a dangerous drug this is a drug that
is has been given the bill in billions of doses
for 70 years it's fda approved and it's so safe in
many countries you don't need a prescription for
it's an over-the-counter drug in other countries
in many other countries um so uh this drug
was safe factually true to be safe but it was
it was distorted by the media and other so-called
experts as being dangerous and therefore
people weren't the reason that was important
is they couldn't even get people to enroll in
the clinical trial that was started because people
were afraid they also did something unprecedented
they they outlawed basically uh prescribing
it doctors always are able to prescribe
fda approved drugs at their discretion for what
they think are reasonable indications this is
the so-called medicine is an art side of things
and in this instance and in my view my knowledge
it's unprecedented pharmacists were refusing
to fill the prescription order from doctors
for these drugs even though these are safe drugs
fda approved drugs uh we see the same thing with
with ivermectin and so uh whether these drugs work
or not there's plenty of indication of data that
suggests that they work the definitive trials that
people wanted to do the double-blinded trials etc
were really not fully done but that's a failure
of the united states public health agencies the
failure to do those studies is a massive
uh egregious public health failure but that
could have been done in months in the summer of
2020 spring summer 2020 it could have been done
because the drugs were already fda approved uh so
uh the answer to why uh is a difficult question
that people ask me uh and i i don't i hate to
attribute motive i don't know it's speculation
but i can say this and this is one of the issues
we're addressing with this academy there is a
very unhealthy entanglement of the control of
scientific research by people in the nih with the
university scientists who need to do that get
the funding to do their research so that they
get promoted and that all is intermingled with
that's the only evidence to publishing in the
major journals to get the grant and the funding
it all is like a circular kind of situation
and the people who review the grants are also the
people that review for the journals and so there
it turns out there's this really very small
cartel almost that controls everyone's career
and so you may wonder why is it that not many
scientists who depend on nih funding spoke out
against some of the things that dr falchi
said well there's one reason their entire
career hinges on nih grant funding and so when
we see uh a letter to the editor in the lancet
in february 2020 by a bunch of very famous
virologists saying it is known in february
2020 that the virus is natural origin and anyone
who says it could be a lavalier is a conspiracy
theorist this is the consensus okay that just
should never even be published in a in a good
scientific journal it's garbage it was also a
lie and you have to wonder why they did that
because they're smart people and i'm not sure
what the answer to y is but it was false from
the get-go the intimidation factor though coming
from that was there was an attempt to stop anybody
from saying it could be a lab leak even though
that was about as common sense as you could get
considering the circumstances so and of course
as things have evolved it's more and more likely
that that is the case anyway so uh it's very
complicated i'm giving another long-winded
answer but um this stuff is very difficult
to sort out because it's a very complex
world and it's a very uh let's say corrupt
world the funding of science the control
of the scientific research and when you have
someone who controls the scientific research
is the same person that controls the public
health policy that is derived from that research
okay that that's that's that's uh that's uh
that's not that's not okay i don't know what the
i don't have the vocabulary to say how
bad that is in polite company yes sir
a little bit off the presentation but um masks
the governor of virginia issued an executive order
that as of today he would leave it to the parents
to decide whether their child should go to school
with a mask or without a mask and that
was totally ignored by fairfax county
just and i i think there's got to be
some sort of critical mass of people
that um stormed that case or something
i just don't know how they're going to
get around that i mean if somebody
says why the hell with you governor
what does he do well your question really is sort
of uh what's going on i think in this country
where there's a lack of um understanding of
what the law is uh in a sense and here we have
i'm not gonna i don't have to go through the
details about mass but suffice it to say that
the scientific data and simple common sense by
the way says that mass are ineffective that's
factually true in preventing the spread of of
this virus and in schools there is data actually
absolute data in florida comparing the schools
that had mask wearing with the children in
schools that didn't have mass wearing and there
was no difference in the number of covet cases
um so the governor of virginia is sane and
rational that's point number one uh point number
two is uh it is completely irrational to force
children to wear masks in schools uh but what
can people do about us the answer and you know
i've always said people ask me when will this be
for months uh you know when will this be ever when
will the cdc say the pandemic is over when will dr
fauci say we don't have to do this or that and
my answer is never they're not going to okay we
should we must be past that that's not the answer
to the problem the answer to the problem is to be
critical thinking adults to have responsibility we
cannot trust people simply because of their titles
we know that now we're not in that world anymore
so we need to become critical thinkers make the
effort listen to people who are sensible who
cite data who are consistent in what they say
look at the numbers yourself it's not that
difficult really i think everything i said
in the presentation is very simple really uh
and then you are responsible for what the best
decisions are for yourself and your family
and particularly your children and anybody
who abrogates that responsibility to the state
for their own children i mean i think that's a
frightening place to live frankly so you know we
have to uh it's a responsibility of the parents
to make the decisions for their children and i
think the governor made a very wise executive
order he didn't forbid people from wearing
masks all he did was he said it's up to the
parent to decide i'm not sure what kind of
country it is that finds that unacceptable
one other quick thing the academy but
you have a room full of people here who
have listened to this excellent presentation
what do you want all of us to do as a result
well uh you know several things number one um
be aware of the existence of this is all new
this is new in in in my view it's pretty broad uh
groundbreaking i don't see the other universities
doing this uh my university isn't doing it um so
uh hillsdale uh is a special kind of place with
a concern for freedom and common sense and and you
know the the founding principles of the country
and freedom and liberty of course is what the
country was founded on and so what we can do
here as a group is spread the word uh contact
people at hillsdale if you want to support this
institute in any way you can whether it's
financial or otherwise uh we're we're frankly
uh if i may say raising uh funds to get
everything done that needs to be done here
this is not a one-off this is a long-term
project we're going to involve some of the
best people there are many people who agree with
me who are very high uh quality or high level
scientists academicians thought leaders in related
fields i mean the media is really the interpreter
of science to the public we need the media at the
table here to figure this out and so we want this
to be more known go to the websites see what
you can do we're going to have another event
every say month or two at least we're going to
involve students we're going to involve the press
and i would say contact the appropriate people
at hillsdale to see if if you can support we need
people's support to really make this as impactful
as possible and we have time for one more question
all right thanks you'll hold on to it okay um
so i'm gonna i i agreed with almost everything
you said but i'm gonna prove your point that
scientists sometimes disagree a little bit and
uh and just and i don't disagree completely but i
want to challenge you a little bit on something so
uh when it so i i agree 100 that people at
high risk and the elderly should have been
the ones we focused on with protection and that
that's who should have gotten the vaccines however
i am concerned about some of the data you
presented related to the vaccine effectiveness
on severe disease and death and i'm just going
to give you a few things to think about you can
comment on so one issue with that data as i've
looked at it is there's some inherent bias in
that epidemiologic data because there are many
people who are at high risk who would also be
much less likely to become vaccinated so whether
it's drug abuse alcoholism maybe they have a
cancer and they're very immunosuppressed so the
doctor wouldn't even bother trying the vaccine
various types of things like that which obviously
uh could have could skew the data in one way or
the other i think the danish study you showed
where you saw the largest drop in effectiveness
dealt with that um to some degree because they
actually matched the demographics of the people in
that study so i think that's actually one of the
best studies that's been done my other concern is
the time in that these are all snapshot studies
and what we know about rna respiratory viruses
is they're constantly changing as we've seen
with the various variants and now omicron and i
believe that and there's actually data now there's
danish data and if you look at israel um you see
that over time larger and larger percentages of
people who are fully vaccinated sometimes boosted
are making up those hospitalized and uh and um and
severe disease and deaths and so i think that when
we end up looking at this over the longer period
of time of the whole sort of episode whether
it's the pandemic or even as we move into an
endemic period we are going to see that that
vaccine effectiveness against severe disease and
death over the long haul will continue to drop
off just as the effectiveness against cases drops
off because of the way this works so again i'm not
saying it doesn't work at all i think it was very
useful and had we targeted the right populations
early on it would have been very effective
because we would have allowed other people
to develop natural immunity that could have ended
up making this move faster to an endemic level but
i i do worry about some of that data that's just
80 90 percent effectiveness against severe disease
over the long haul because i just don't think
those numbers are going to hold up yeah well i
mean i i would say it's absolutely true and
i i try to say this in various ways is that
this is very short term we don't know
what's going to happen i completely agree
uh we we of course think that there's going to be
some drop-off in all of the protections over time
that's what we're seeing there's a trend toward
that but what we have is what we have and so
at this point in time my point of showing those
slides is not that a vaccine is 90 effective
against stopping death it doesn't have to be to
be worth taking uh if you're a high-risk person
uh you know that's a heck of a lot better than
what the flu vaccine does for the same people okay
when you look at the data on the flu vaccine and
the people who die from the flu besides the young
children are the same elderly and firm people and
when you look at the efficacy there's a lot of
question about how how well of how effective the
flu vaccines are not just because the flu virus
changes this virus changes too uh but you're
right i mean the bottom line is i agree with
you the story needs to play out we don't know
but if somebody but what i hate to see is the
uh sort of uh confusion that people have
that are high risk that because you get in
very poor protection against an infection with
a mild disease that means you don't that the
vaccine doesn't work at all i'm very concerned
with that i think that's a that's a misconception
uh in terms of so far it looks pretty good
at protecting death it's against death it's
probably true that it's going to wane it didn't
wane in the sweden data we know that and i
happen to trust the sweden data and so of course
we'll see over time uh but it's not clear to me
what with the story will be written uh how
the story will be written because now we know
with omicron and so many people who have been
vaccinated that got the infection that the data on
uh the smaller percentage of people in the
end who had the vaccine but never infected
i'm not even sure a lot of those
people won't have had the infection
because the infection is so commonly
asymptomatic and i think that is another
contaminant of all these studies they never
prove these people never had the infection
when they categorize people who's vaccinated
but uninfected they mean they'd have never had
the symptoms of covet or a positive covalent
test doesn't mean they never had the infection
half the cases are asymptomatic and with omicron
probably more so you're right there's still uh the
vaccine story is not fully written i agree i just
think it's um it's a problem if people have jumped
to saying the vaccines don't work i i don't agree
with that statement so far let's see what happens
okay thank you very much
nothing
you